U.S household debt now surpasses 17
trillion dollars now here's what's
interesting Dave comparing that to the
European Union which has more households
and yet less than half of that amount in
debt which tells me that debt is the
most aggressively marketed product in
American history and we are so good
America is number one in a lot of things
and debt is one of them marketing is one
of them and here's a great quote from a
Stanford economic sociologist being
financially responsible in the U.S has
come to mean borrow and repay
that pretty much sums up how you've been
doing this for 30 years Dave
everyone was told if you want to be
financially responsible borrow money and
repay it back and do that over and over
again until you die and then maybe one
day you'll hopefully be able to retire
it's insane